une dernière chose rachid petite voix
son prénom commence par jim feeny paref
m'a dit que belmondo n'a pas rompu les
relations avec vos enfants tournage qu'à
noël vous aviez de ses nouvelles est ce
que vous confirmez oui bien sûr alors
c'est très particulier c'est très dur
même pour moi de retranscrire la
relation que j'ai pu avoir avec
jean-paul parce que c'était vraiment une
relation je voudrais partir et ça c'est
à ses enfants et ses petits-enfants par
respect mais on avait vraiment une
relation de père fils est très
particulier parce que je pense qu'il a
protégé ce gamin sur le film il m'a
donné toute sa confiance et
pour vous et à noël vous resservir de
ces nouvelles du sport et à noël en fait
il faisait venir des cadeaux pour la
famille
un titre bien quoi
et valeur avec une très grande haine ni
rodier ouais
on est très émus votre élection notre
émotion se communique à tout le monde je
vous laisse je vous laisse voilà avec
vos souvenirs je me tourne vers laurence
taille et on a parlé de belmondo et des
femmes il ya toujours une bonne occasion
de parler d'ursula andress mais vous la
place qu'occupe pour vous belmondo en
tant qu'homme et en tant capteur est ce
que c'est votre genre là
c'est un très bel homme
on peut le dire bonjour
la question
avait été présentée effectivement
j'aurais dit oui bon c'était pas mal
question non plus
c'est bien des répondants
mal en
complète maintenant l'artiste l'artiste
ce qui m'a marqué en fait c'est sa très
grande modestie et sa simplicité comment
peut-on être aussi puissant aussi
merveilleux et aussi modeste alors j'ai
cherché un petit peu et ils disaient
vous parliez de son papa justement qu'il
avait tiré cette grande modestie de son
papa qui était un grand artiste mais
très modeste mais ça je crois que c'est
une qualité qui fait la quintessence
justement de ce que peut être un acteur
dans sa puissance c'est de conserver en
fait le fait que comme l'a dit le
président de la république je veux pas
tronqué ses propos que j'ai entendus
mais que j'ai pas noté il disait on
l'aimé parce qu'il nous ressembler et
c'est vrai qu'en fait c'était l'acteur
de tous les français si pour cet hommage
était essentielle même si on a entendu
quelques voix très peu nombreuses qui
l'ont contesté parce que tous les
français aujourd'hui sont meurtris alors
il y avait bien sûr les personnalités
qui étaient présentes mais il y avait
aussi beaucoup d'anonymes qui est arrivé
hier déjà pour pouvoir approcher et qui
ont pu continuer à aller le voir et
c'est assez la france en fait qui a
perdu un peu un pendent un pont
d'elle-même